parce que nous sommes amis bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors le ministre indien de la justice
ainsi que des technologies de
l'information s'inquiètent notamment que
facebook ait pu jouer un rôle dans les
élections législatives de 2010 9 qui
attire des éléments qui permettent
d'appuyer cette hypothèse
en fait je ne pense pas avec l'aide
logistique actuelle et les données que
nous possédons mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que yens
une sorte d' influence médias qui est
plus fort que facebook lui-même mais si
je prends un petit peu l'inde
quand même se situer les premiers airs
utilisateurs de page facebook dans le
monde actuellement avec 241 millions les
personnes qui ont accès à facebook avec
un compte facebook
et n'oublions pas non plus que l'inde a
une population de 1 milliard 300
millions dans lequel nous avons à peu
près les leçons millions de personnes
qui ont droit devaux sur lequel on n'a
pas plus de un tiers de personnes qui
ont accès à internet c'est à dire nous
avons 50 % de pénétration de l'internet
mais il est effort évident qu'il ya une
certaine influence de ces milliards dans
l'actualité mais dans les données
actuelles je ne pense pas que facebook a
une influence que ce soit à gauche ou
droite mais c'est plutôt les populations
locales qui ont décidé en masse par
rapport à un agenda local qui a ramené 7
vote au budget puis actuelle la
gouvernement actuel l'opposition
reproche également au réseau social de
ne pas avoir censuré nombre de propos
haineux envers la communauté musulmane
vous comprenez cette position où j'ai
pense que c'est dans les deux sens ça
c'était un moment facebook a été
reproché par la partie congress et on
les personnes plus vulnérables aux
populations indien n'a pas aidé
suffisamment pour atténuer certaines un
conflit social et deux côtés de
gouvernement aussi nous avons dit que
tout ce qui est actualisée sur les
gouvernements c'est à dire la
construction de soi la construction de
temples ayodya ou soit à les actions par
rapport aux hindous comme on appelle un
ss facebook avait banni certaines pages
qui que envie ni mes envies mais le
conflit social mais il est il est vrai
que les employés de facebook canam ont
procédé à souvent à dessein sur par
rapport aux sensibilités locales
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit pris
ils ont pris parti soit à gauche à
droite mais tout dépendra des actions
qui ont qui ont mené un temps à l'autre
parce que si on dit qu'elle facebook a
supprimé les pages concernant le
gouvernement actuel
ils ont aussi supprimé les pages
concernant les les parties gauche comme
la partie aux gestes banals aussi bien
les partis du congrès ce rapidement
récemment new delhi a interdit plusieurs
centaines d'applications chinoise dont
la
très populaire application tik tok qui
fait ravage actuellement ce
qu'aujourd'hui facebook
plus largement d'ailleurs les légendes
du numérique américains peuvent profiter
des mauvaises relations qui existent
actuellement entre l'inde et la chine
écoutez l'histoire de l'inde et chinon
quelques mots les chinois ils ont ils
ont un agenda très bien défini depuis
les années 60 et actuel président xi
jinping qui est le secrétaire général de
la partie commence à impliquer appliquer
son agenda qui était définie depuis 1967
à vire dis moi c'est tout cas il aurait
déjà décidé d'avoir les fameux line 1
verte comme il appelle les lignes vertes
c'est pratiquement vous avez une grosse
partie du nord-est et il considère aussi
un match piège qui est un état indien
quand un état qui appartient en chine
aussi bien vous avez la partie jammu
cachemire
une partie de la dac aux pratiques ou au
ladakh qu'ils considèrent comme fait
partie de chine
c'est un agenda qui était déjà défini
prédéfinis par ces par sept partis au
pouvoir depuis 1960 est évidemment en
profitons de la pandémie actuelle et
voyons la faiblesse de l'état indienne
avec les pandémies ils ont avancé sur
cette période très bien en tout cas
merci beaucoup
raja rameaux à demi-nus famille d'avoir
répondu alors qu'est ce